casey maize on the mound 21st start for
the tigers they call it a cutter they
call it slider whatever it is opponents
are hitting 178 against it
first time durant has ever faced casey
mize
swung on and missed casey mize has the
first out of the night and it's a
strikeout of joran duran
see the numbers for bogarts he was one
for three yesterday at a single in the
third inning here's the pitch swing in a
line drive into right field a base set a
little fisted looper and that'll do the
trick as [ __ ] heads over to third and
the red sox have action here in the
first not zander's loudest contact but
hey when you're in a funk sometimes you
need those and the red sox have them at
the corners with one down they're
threatening for another one here rafael
devers
on the ground could be two short steps
on the bag the relay
in time
devers frustrated mize relieved zach
short with a solid defensive play early
on to be a difference maker so the focus
flips to eduardo rodriguez in the bottom
half as the tigers come to bat eddie
making his 21st start overall a 5.6 era
there yeah it's up to e-rod right now to
put some zeros up here early give this
offense a chance the game you need 2-2
beautiful pitch fastball on the outside
corner ring him up i don't know whether
that's the four seamer or the cutter it
was moving away from the left-handed
hitter paint from eddie and there's one
down here's robbie grossman now the 2-2
to right field
a base hit for robbie grossman jonathan
scope will dig for third he will cruise
in there standing up and like the red
sox in their half of the first the
tigers put runners at the corners with
only one away
first and third with one out for miguel
cabrera here's the pitch swing and a
miss he struck him out elevated fastball
perfectly placed on the outside corner
huge second out down goes cabrera and
now here's eric haas the one-two
fastball swing and a miss he just stayed
upstairs and haas could not get there
don't waste the pitch and just stay
there adios says eddie and that's really
important he gets through the jam in the
first we've played an inning no score in
motel martinez 288 20 homers and 67
driven in
martinez stings this one toward right
center field back to the wall and gone
an opposite field shot for jd martinez
and the red sox strike first in the
second that is a beautiful swing by jd
gets a fastball coming back to him just
a little bit
just a little bit got too much of the
plate and he put a swing on and that's
the swing we've missed for a while
probably for about a good 10 games
see this ball sinks back to him gets the
barrel to it that's his swing right
center field
he's just hoping he had enough to hit it
out of here they play alex verdugo to
pull instead verdugo strikes out on
three pitches one away in the second one
nothing jamer condolario the switch it
will bat right against rodriguez in this
second inning 2-2
and the candyman strikes out so four
outs all via the poncho for rodriguez
235 homer and seven driven in for the
right-handed hitting catcher
one two to grinder
got him swinging
five outs all strikeouts for rodriguez
need to tell you he's got it working
tonight christian vasquez batting out of
the nine spot for the red sox tonight
casey mize from the wind up lined right
back through the middle for a base hit
mize had to duck out of the way of that
one
vasquez put a good bat on the ball and
lined it right back up through the box
the scope certainly hit a ball hard his
first time up
but giving it to hall of fame
the looper
get down
scope on his way to second tigers get a
break with one away here in the third
well scope is on here in front of the
three-hole hitter robbie grossman erods
1-2
he strikes out grossman
punch-out number six for rodriguez big
league change-up that's his pitch man he
made a pitch right there xander bogarts
will lead things off against casey mize
he was laughing to him as he took it too
this one is fired by bogarts down the
line fairball gets into the left field
corner bounces around bogart's heads for
second
started to put it into cruise control
then thought maybe i gotta just pick it
up and maybe think three but he stops
there at second base with a lead off
double facing eric haas
and striking out eric haas seven k's he
elevates with heat
and a punch out to begin the fourth for
rodriguez renfro to lead it off against
casey mize will be renfro cordero and
vasquez renfro swings and lines one down
the right field line and that is a fair
ball and that'll be extra bases here we
go again with the lead off man and
damage for the red sox renfro has his
21st double a beautiful swing he'll turn
it back over to the top for [ __ ]
hernandez the man at third the 3-2
and hernandez pulls this one to left
badoo is back and that is goal
much needed for the red sox says [ __ ]
hernandez makes it a three-nothing lead
oh he's the difference here comes [ __ ]
and it wasn't a fastball
how about that 3-2 little spin ball and
he he goes bridge nicely done got the
runner in third to come in two-run
shot makes it three-nothing
how about a little spinner for you
that's a little spin job and he crushes
this ball you know it's gone just look
at him
tells you everything
1-0 pitch his lash the other way this
ball hit well it is back and it is gone
duran goes back to back with keikai and
the red sox lead at four to nothing
duran rounded second base looked at john
lipka the second base home part and said
did it go
you just had his head down he was taken
off right away that little two seamer
away
that caught a lot of the plate
going durant stayed on this ball it was
a rocket out of left field wasn't it
wouldn't even hit high at all he did
that in the seventh inning last night a
line drive the other way this thing got
out by maybe a foot or maybe
that brings up derek hill upstairs again
for another strikeout for rodriguez
who's up to eight boy and the whiffs
just keep coming and now turns the
lineup over for the third time 3-2
strike three called on the outside
corner absolute paint two down
and rodriguez
gearing up for pitch number 99 in this
one one two
that is strike three call
10 strikeouts for rodriguez in five
shutout tonight jonathan scope the only
tiger tonight to be on base three times
how about that
that is gone
pulverized to left center field number
18 for jonathan scope
tigers are on the board traveling four
to one here in the seventh
got behind in the count that's right
where the
first inning foul ball was you see
taylor right there the pitcher just hit
the ground
jonathan knew immediately jonathan scope
the batter 2-2
barnes does to finish it up and the red
sox win with 18 strikeouts from the
pitching staff
love it you gotta love it been rooting
for strikeouts all night long from the
get-go
swings and misses just to stay in shape
from detroit all night long
it's a 4-1 win three home runs the sox
snap the skid